لكن بينما يغلب التركيز الان على انتهاكات
النظام الايراني ركزت مجله ناشونال انترست
في تقرير حديث لها على اخطاء الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه في التعامل مع ايران حث حيث
اعتمرت المجال لان هذه الاستراتيجيه تواجه
ثغرات عديده سمحت لايران بالافلات من
العقوبات المفروضه عليها
بالتوازي مع عرقله عمليه تطوير الصواريخ
واشارت المجله
الى عمليه تبادل تكنولوجيا هذه الطائرات
بين
وشركائها والوكلاء داخل وخارج الشرق
الاوسط المجله الامريكيه استخدام نموذج
العصا والجزره وفقا معايير محدده بحيث
يتوزع بين الضغوط القصوى التي تتضمن
التلويح بعمل عسكري وبالعقوبات الاقتصاديه
وبين الانخراط الدبلوماسي وتخفيف العقوبات
بهدف تغيير سلوك النظام
الاخيره التي فرضتها واشنطن الشهر الجاري
على اعضاء بمنظمه القدس للطيران والصناعات
الفضائيه التابعه للحرس الثوري
طائرات مهاجر سته التي يعتقد بان ايران
زودت بها روسيا في حرب اوكرانيا
ربما تكون بدايه الضغط الذي تتحدث عنه
ناشونال انترست من التنسيق مع اسرائيل
فالسفير الامريكي هناك قال ان قائد
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه مايكل كوريلا
بحثا مع وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي وفالنت
تقويه التحالف ضد الاخطار الاقليميه وخاصه
ايران
الاقليميه خاصه من النظام الايراني الخطير
والمدمر الذي ينتهك حقوق شعبه كانت ضمن
الملفات التي تمت مناقشتها في الاجتماع